for the giants johnny cueto the veteran
right-hander with his 11th start of the
year he is four and three with a
4.00 earned run average so double
herrera will lead things off against
right-hander johnny cueto herrera in
center field
i thought it's hammered deep center way
back there it is gone
oh double herrera leads off the game
with a home run
just as did kyle schwarber in washington
against cueto on sunday
oduba herrera's fifth home run this year
and just like that one nothing phillies
maybe o'double with the hat on now has
figured something out with his swing and
he can keep that same approach
is that the homer that is the homer
something
and up comes bryce harper
the crawford
he speared it one
double
play man that ball was hit hard
that
is magical
i mean you this
is this reactionary you know the ball is
going to short hop you put yourself in
the best position you can
i mean the balance the feed to second
everything you need from a gold glove
shortstop and that's why he's one of the
best
hey look at the reaction from jerry
rollins mccutch is the guy that's got
the best lifetime numbers against johnny
cueto one two pitch mccutcheon hits it
hard on the ground but that's the third
fossler will throw all the way across in
time to get mccutcheon and johnny cueto
gets some help from his defense there
gives up the run on the lead off home
run but the giants
kicked it clean behind him after that
and so just the one
for the phillies a half inning in the
books here tonight on this beautiful
friday in san francisco phillies one
giants coming up tonight vince velasquez
will start it off on the mound for the
phillies a two-in-one mark of 425 era
for vince that'll bring up brandon belt
long hold now the pitch
and a swing at him is he struck him out
so the two out walk
nothing more than that against vince
velasquez here in the bottom of the
first
inning number two the giants and the
phillies
on a friday night in san francisco brad
miller one-two pitch swing and a miss
strike three cueto gets his first
strikeout so now alec baum who's been
swinging the bat much better is kind of
a slow start for him he's a talented
young hitter two and two with luke
williams on deck
here's the swivel and the pitch swung on
it missed strike three he got him at 94
miles an hour cueto's throwing hard
tonight that's his second strikeout in a
row two down
jason fossler now one and one the count
and that is into shallow right base hit
crawford bought the deak
here comes the throw it's offline
crawford had started back to third base
when harper
decked as if they were going to catch
that ball
one to one
here's wade
giant says an offense had the third best
chase rate
in all the baseball so they chase less
frequently than almost everybody now a
smash liner off the glove of hoskins
it's going to roll into foul territory
down the first base line in to score
duggar around the third vosser he'll
stop there as miller the second baseman
chased after the ball and finally got to
it but lamont wades into second with a
double the giants have a 2-1 lead they
have runners at second and third with
two down and
mike ustremski who has really heated up
coming to the plate with buster posey on
deck
two one pitch yostremski takes in this
one gets by nap it's going to the
backstop he'll throw home bossler slides
in and the throw gets away from home
plate
wade though will
start to come home and then stop and go
back as the phillies scramble after the
ball rolling on the infield grass it's
three to one giants velasquez ready
here's the pitch
swung on and popped up
this one towards third backpedaling is
balm and he's got a speed on it he makes
the catch boy looked a little dicey
there for a moment
and he ends up making the catch just a
few steps out into the outfield grass so
now andrew mccutchen
the pitch and this one's swung on hit in
the air deep center field duggar going
back track wall it's gone into the
philly's bullpen
andrew mccutchen with a two-run home run
and he has tied the ball game here in
the fourth inning
it is 3-3
stay hot catch and the batter will be
lamont wade
3-3 that's the score bottom four
the pitch to wade is hit high and deep
to right center field harper chasing
after it so is herrera and herrera dives
and he can't catch it it bounces on the
track plato sprinting around third he'll
score over to third is lamont way junior
with a triple
to put the giants back ahead 4-3 the
walk to the pitcher
burns the phillies and johnny cueto i've
never seen him run faster yastremski has
popped out twice
against velasquez he's over two
and the pitch
swung on a hit in the air
right center field harper ranging over
to his right he's calling for it he
makes the catch
and the sides retired with the damage
done the two-out walk
comes home to score and the phillies
find themselves trailing yet again we're
going to the fifth inning tonight in san
francisco three-man shift right side
against brandon belt here's the wind-up
and the 2-2 pitch belt blasts one deep
right field and he can watch it it's
sailing and up to the top of the arcade
and gone
and maybe gonna bounce down to the port
walk we'll see not a splash home run but
a booming homer for belt is tenth of the
year
five to three giants
and bryce harper now
another 3-2 to bryce harper he drives
this one to left field wade's sprinting
back still going back this one's going
to go over his head bounce off the wall
wade plays the carob wheels around here
comes his throw the tag he is out at
second
what a throw from lalon way junior
and donovan solano is going to hit
the wind up in the pitch solano fouls
one off the mask of knapp who goes down
he just tumbled over sideways there
after taking that shot to the face mask
the pitch swinging a miss he got him
the phillies
changing catchers here
as
we hope that andrew knapp is okay but it
catches him right in the chin and it
almost knocks him out
how he managed to stay in the game i
have no idea
well that'll leave it up to brad miller
there goes mccutcheon
the ground ball in the right field the
long throw
in time
and the ball game is over